[Music]
[Applause]
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host of course football night in
america haven't talked to you since that
play but just explain the logic i know
mike mccarthy's trying to protect dak
prescott you know i was also told that
two plays were called that there would
have been a pass play and then there
would have been the draw on that because
on the run one of the wide receivers is
going out for a pass he's not even
blocking so no no right
i'm trying to understand here we did was
it the right call
i think you you hit on it you said some
really good things right there
you know again he's mike mccarthy's not
wrong and that the referee can just
touch it and go but you know there's
things in that process
my history is this can you get a play
off in that situation with 12 13 14
seconds yes you can but i'm not sure you
can get a 17-yard rushing attempt up the
middle off in that in 14 seconds and to
me with any team i've been around and
you know
whether it's john gruden or the new
england patriots and josh mcdaniels the
threshold for a play for anything let's
say over 10 yards to be safe to like
your point to where we're not going oh
my gosh we might have .8 seconds of
wiggle room here or one second of wiggle
room is 17 seconds that's how i was
always coaching those situations
and i think that holds true you know if
dak prescott slides 10 yards earlier
five yards earlier fine that'll be okay
you know if he just dumps off a little
slant over the middle let's just say to
amari cooper boom he gets it he goes
down nobody's run all over the field
they're expecting to clock it right
there where he catches the ball okay 14
seconds gonna work 17-yard rushing gain
no i don't know about that and then what
it comes into play too is like you're
talking about just the process and how
they did it you roll out the red carpet
for the referee i don't know what dak
prescott was looking at necessarily in
that situation and with that type of
play too the touch spot to me is
questionable as well as far as mccarthy
is explaining it because again dak
prescott started the slide on the 26
yard line the cowboys decided to spot
the ball on the 23 right they gave
themselves three yards like oh we're the
cowboys we'll just give ourselves three
yards how dare they want to spot the
ball in the correct place so there was
those issues as well and even within
that the referee who did a good job
hustling down there and trying to help
out the cowboys dak prescott runs into
him man he was wrong in the fact that he
didn't even spot the ball in the right
spot he was the whole cowboy team is
offsides really too so to me again not a
bad call it's just a process of how they
went about it that i think is a little
skeptical at this point all right let's
move to the playoff teams you have more
confidence in ryan tannehill to win a
game for the titans or jimmy garoppolo
to win a game for the niners uh ryan
tannehill 100 percent like i mean we're
talking about like you know just you're
you're you're you're under the pressure
a hundred percent yes i do okay 100
percent there's no wiggling
um i like jimmy g we know it but i mean
come on come on we all know it's a flip
of the coin sometimes at the end of the
football game with him just like last
week it's 23 to 7. brandon ayook's wide
open there's nobody in the screen
they're gonna put the game away right
there he misses the throw the
interception itself it was a five yard
crossing route he did not get the ball
within five feet of the receiver he
couldn't even get a hand on it
interception so that i worry about tana
hill doesn't do stuff like that he has
great control of the football you know
and he's a really accurate thrower so i
mean i think you're asking me like four
minutes left in the game what
quarterback would i take i'm taking tana
hill
and i wonder
how much can you how much do the bengals
expect to see derek henry this weekend
i i think they got to prepare for we're
going to see the full effect of him okay
uh just to get your mind right you know
and of course if he is there and it is
the full effect of him you got to make
sure you got your game plan in the right
way and then the ducks in a row as far
as stopping that aspect so i would
approach it if i'm the bangles to go
it's gonna be derek henry time let's
just get our minds ready for that and if
it's not him great we dodged a bullet we
don't have to deal with him that much
great that's awesome but i would be more
worried about that aspect than not and
yes he's hey he's a game changer we know
that he's his first ballot hall of famer
running back in my opinion one of the
all-time greats and he can break an
80-yard run or when there's nothing
there to be had he could still get three
or four yards and to me the other thing
that's going to really be a jump off
thing jump off spot is he's going to
open up their play-action pass game they
want to be like the
2003-2004 patriots they want to run the
ball play defense
brady make some clutch big throws for us
and some big moments they're going to
ask tannehill to do that i think that's
the way they want to play
i'm excited for that game i have pleaded
with the audience football fans the
media
we got to come up with a better nickname
than joe cool for joe burrow that's not
fair that's not fair to montana
yeah you're right you're right and
you've said joe cool you you said this
on football night in america
that's that you should be ashamed of
yourself i you know you're right i mean
good for you to slap me around a little
bit yeah get on me yeah we do have to go
it is disrespectful to the original joe
cool i mean burrow is
he's cool so it's just easy to go with
that but i i don't know i'm not that
creative i'm waiting for broadway joe i
mean you know oh yeah you're right i
don't know what street he lives on in
cincinnati but i hope it's not broadway
because it'd be like yeah broadway joe
no you can't have that one either no you
can't have a you're right we can't
infringe on copyright you know as far as
great nicknames that way but uh one
thing i always call him is
a slippery sob that's what i do call him
the natural that's another nickname i
can't take that one either i know okay
that's just a movie it's not a real
person so i thought maybe i could go
there with that one but something along
those lines because man i love watching
joe burrow i love that offense and even
though i think people are disrespecting
the titans the titans their past defense
this offense coming to the town who's
got every play in the book and talent i
think that could be an interesting game
just because of borough and and that
offense and how they run things give me
your quarterback ratings i always have
great respect for how you rank
quarterbacks those who are still in the
playoffs give me these eight
quarterbacks and how you who's won
and how they're playing right now
right okay so number one is
man you're putting me under the gun here
i think i'd go right now and i
understand aaron rodgers is the mvp of
football i'd probably put josh allen
number one right now i'd probably go
alan won
i would you know alan and mahomes even
though you know even mahomes didn't have
his greatest year
to me are just they're they're so
dangerous in these situations you know
they're like rogers was let's say four
or five years ago rogers needs again now
a little protection he can't make the
magic happen as far as extending plays
like he used to you know remember the
old days he used to sit back there and
hop and wiggle around and move and make
people miss and then oh if i got to
break the pocket i will you know that's
kind of my homes and allen now you can't
contain them in the pocket put a
quarterback spy on them great i watch it
all the time it doesn't do jack diddley
squat so there's just so many plays
where i look at and i go the defense won
this play and these two damn guys still
got a 20-yard gain and that's where
they're amazing so i'd probably go allen
one mahomes to
rogers three
brady
four
just over borough five
stafford six tana hills seven garoppolo
eight
you okay with that yeah yeah i i
josh allen threw the perfect game
in the game against the patriots that's
as good of football as you could play
and mahomes take away the strip
sack or the exactly the the strip six
he threw five touchdown passes in less
than 11 minutes yeah right i've never
seen anything like the kansas city
chiefs they're like the golden state
warriors from a few years ago you go oh
this team's up by 10 and they're
controlling the game and they'll send
you look and you go what the warriors
are up by 20. yeah
it's four minutes later how did this
happen i've never seen a team that can
just catch on fire like the kansas city
chiefs i'm really excited for that one
to me i think we're getting close to
this is the modern day manning brady is
alan versus mahomes you know mahomes we
know
is
in all probably greater than josh allen
we know he's won the super bowl he's you
know won two afc championship games but
i will say this josh allen has outplayed
patrick mahomes the last two seasons in
the nfl he's the greatest one-man show
in the sport right now i mean oh hey
it's third and two we need a first down
oh just let's pull two guards and give
the ball to josh allen and he'll run up
in there and run for a 40-yard gain like
he's cam newton oh now we need him to
scramble or be precise with passing he's
got it all just like mahomes except
maybe a little bit more size uh and
ability to move the chains with his legs
and a traditional running
form there he's chris sims from football
night in america pro football talk live
co-host with mike florio yeah i there
were there were times when i didn't want
josh allen or any of my quarterbacks to
run now when i watch buffalo i realize
he has to run and he's such a valuable
weapon the quarterback with the most
pressure
this weekend is
i think it's uh oh aaron rodgers
i think that's the one i would look at
again he's he is very legacy aware but
what are we talking about if the packers
lose to the niners
if the packers lose to the niners we're
going to just hear
all the same stuff we always hear from
people who want to hate or be negative
about aaron ah he lost a big game again
he can't win the big one they're the
number one seed and they lost at home to
the 49ers which i understand i mean
those
that's legitimate i get that you know i
know again again there's a few times i'd
say hey the seattle nfc championship
game that wasn't his fault come on you
know last year certainly wasn't his
fault either did some really good things
outplayed brady we know that but there's
been other games where they the falcons
and and the 49ers the first time around
there a few years ago yeah it wasn't
good you know this is big not only i
think for him personally but just in the
scope and the eyes of the normal common
football fan you know if they lose this
everyone looks at them as the super bowl
contender and i'm one that's been saying
i don't think the packers are a super
bowl team i don't know if that
necessarily means i'm not going to pick
them this week but i think the 49ers
posed some real issues for them i bet
you when they saw they had to play the
49ers they went ah man i wish we were
playing the rams they match up better
with them you know and that's where it's
going to be scary and i would not be
shocked that the 49ers went up there and
upset green bay this weekend
the rams will upset the buccaneers
because of their offense or their
defense
yeah it's
their defense has the number of the
bucks offense and the fact of the bucks
there's very few defenses they don't
actually match up well and you go oh
advantage bucks but the rams are one of
those where i go oh i don't know there
might be an actual advantage here for
the rams and one of the few teams every
team's got their kryptonite buck's so
big and powerful up front the rams are
all small and size predicated i mean
their defensive tackle aaron donald is
280. grain gains is only 290. they don't
have those big space eaters like evita
bayer and dama consu but that poses
problems for a bigger lumbering
offensive line for the bucks who have
not who have shown in the last two years
their inability to
you know kind of get get hold of these
guys in the run game and they're able to
beat them in the pass rush as well so i
guess i would look at that as again it
goes back to something we talk about a
lot with brady you can get there with
the ford disrupt him with that we know
the one weak part of his game is he can
get a little flinchy in the pocket but
here's one other aspect dan that i think
is real interesting too because i do
think the rams are going to be able to
move the ball on this buck's defense can
they protect stafford well enough and
especially without without whitworth
there the d-line for the bucks is
healthy i think the rams pose some real
problems for the bucks but i do worry
about their ability to block all four of
those guys that's probably the weak spot
of the team in my opinion with the rams
is the offensive line coach dwell they
do things the right way it's just not
overly talented and this is a game i'd
be worried about that i'm getting
smashed a little bit up front i'll leave
you with this
tell me why jim harbaugh would leave
michigan and let's say it is the raiders
why would he leave now
i think he just wants to be in the nfl i
think that's where i look at it you know
i think he looks at the nfl and goes
wait that maybe suits me better you know
i don't have to talk and be weird in
recruiting kids or parents because i'm
weird socially anyways and jim harbaugh
and i think that's his lifelong dream
i do i think to win a super bowl do that
but again like the one thing i
i don't hear anything from the people i
know in football and you know i know
some people to know that there's
legitimate interest for any for jim
harbaugh to me i think he's putting this
out there he's fishing he would like to
leave michigan i guess to go back to the
nfl and and just have that lifestyle
again college is a different game
there's less x's and o's it's more about
talking conversations with parents kids
managing a situation and i don't know i
could never do that and i can imagine
him getting sick of that as well
is it the right move for the raiders
that's questionable you know the writers
have some things there about their
coaching staff that i would be real
careful about letting go of rich versace
and the rest of that crew there
like you watch the raiders i watch the
raiders i don't sit there and go oh my
gosh they're so talented man did they
underperform this year they should have
been in the championship game or the
super bowl no
not at all you know besatya i do think
is worthy of being a head coach greg
olsen's a good offensive coordinator gus
bradley does a good job with that
defense he invented the seattle scheme i
wouldn't just throw that out the window
for anybody and you know yeah and and
not for jim harbaugh where again i know
after three years everybody gets sick of
him you know he treats people not the
greatest at times he didn't treat me
good i don't like him i root for against
them all the time i don't like jim
harbaugh you know it's wait what did
harbaugh do to you oh he was such a jerk
one of my first interviews i ever had at
bleacher report um
he he stopped the interview like after
my third question because i asked him
about colin kaepernick's contract
situation
and he took off his mic and said see i'm
done with this and tell your dad i said
hi and that was it so from that point on
i root against i root for ohio state
always and root against jim harbaugh
screw him but he was thoughtful to say
tell your dad hi yeah what a nice guy
what a nice guy and then i know too many
stories about again everything coaches
that have worked for him hey he went to
michigan he took the job he didn't even
tell any of his coaches in the san
francisco staff he just called them it
was like hey i'm in michigan i'm staying
here you guys figure it out yourselves
oh great coach thanks for being such a
great leader so stuff like that where
i'm uh very loving of john harbaugh i
think he's the man and has the midas
touch with people jim not so much could
you take harbaugh
would i take harbaugh could you take him
yes i can right now at this i mean he's
he's a scary sob and he's weird and he's
tough there's no doubt but he's not
taking me right now at my age okay who
are you guys taking let me ask the dan
answer paulie i mean i'm going to
harbaugh because
harbaugh's got crazy strength like he he
would do whatever it would take he would
chew off his arm to get out of you know
one of your i am the guy that lost the
spleen and kept playing it i got crazy
strength too all right
yeah this is tough i mean
horrible harbaugh's probably got two
spleens knowing him with all that milk
he's digesting you know what uh chris is
younger he's got a lot more reach but he
would have to kill harbaugh for the
fight to be over and i don't chris isn't
mean like that
okay you're right i don't want to kill
anybody see you got sims or horrible uh
you know i've met uh jack harbaugh and i
don't see any way that his son is losing
a fight wow have you met phil sims i
mean have you met him well that is true
because i'm making fill over jack all
day long well no i would say i would
take your dad okay your dad's your dad's
a tough guy uh fritzy you're taking sims
or harbaugh i gotta go chris he's an
extremely nice guy but i have a feeling
he can flip that switch and find that
dark side of kind of
it i definitely can i'm the
temperamental person in my family or out
of all my friends you guys just haven't
seen it but now that you picked so many
of you picked harbaugh you're gonna see
it next time i come up there i'm gonna
see it i'm gonna put all your asses in a
headlock and we'll see and you'll
understand what we're talking about here
have a great weekend chris you too man
be good you jerks all of you you're all
jerks this time thank you buddy you know
if we get sims when he's on his
medicinal marijuana trip then i'm okay
he's more chill we could take him